[Music]
this morning on the dish chef Tim
Cushman a native of Boston his first
training wasn't in food but in jazz and
classical guitar the city's renowned
Berklee College of Music while pursuing
his musical dreams in California he
worked in restaurants and discovered a
whole new passion he spent the next
three decades cooking around the world
including Japan and it's there he found
his culinary heart his oh yah in Boston
has been recognized as one of the top
sushi restaurants in the nation earning
him a James Beard Award as Best Chef in
the Northeast
since then he's opened the Hojo ko
Japanese Tavern in Boston and a branch
of oh yah and the California cuisine
inspired Covina here in New York chef
Tim Cushman welcome to the dish thank
you for having me tell us about this
great table okay starting over here we
have the grilled salmon hand roll sushi
following that we have wood grilled
shrimp over heirloom polenta the next
dish is some hummus with seasonal
vegetables in the middle here we have
our Wagyu burgers with our special dashi
pickle special sauce and for dessert we
always like to have pizza so okay this
is my kind of meal if we're having pizza
for dessert so over here we have a pizza
margherita and a mushroom and pepperoni
pizza here to the left and a fantastic
beer that we're drinking yes and the
beers are drinking they're two of my
favorite New England beers one is Cheers
oh here Sears you've actually mixed the
two beers yes one is a mole which is a
main beer company and that's from Maine
and the other one is aeronaut brewing
hop hopping away they're both IPAs but I
actually mix them fifty-fifty I drink
them individually also in a way you have
an eclectic background and reading about
you you grew up you were like captain of
every sports team then you suddenly get
into music and I mentioned you're at a
renowned music school and you end up
cooking how does all of that end up
happening so I was playing sports in
high school and then but I loved music
and then in the 70s I was gonna into
bands and got involved in music went to
Berklee and graduated in 1980 and moved
out to California for the music industry
you were at in LA trying to become Jimi
Hendrix but
I was I was I didn't want to go on tour
so I want a need to get a job I had a
choice of either getting a job in a
restaurant or at a ski store which I
wanted to get but I didn't have a car so
I had to choose the restaurant lucky us
we're good where did the Japanese thing
come from in 1983-84 I worked with a
Japanese chef named Roy Yamaguchi and I
became one of his sous chefs and I was
with him for about a year or two and and
that but that was a very eclectic mix he
was born in Japan he lived in California
and his French trained so that whole
combination fit right into the
California food style and that really
became the foundation of how I cooked
along with him and another chef Michael
Roberts but also my first trip to Japan
1987 was incredible experience and been
back several times since then but that
was a very eye-opening experience I
think we described it as your culinary
heart where did the idea for Oh Yan
Boston come from the first incarnation
of it started at a restaurant in Chicago
when I was living in Chicago it was a
modern Mexican restaurant called Hat
dance which I opened with let us
entertain you Richard Richard Melman
this was around 1989 and had a raw bar
that I idea that I wanted to implement
into the restaurant and so I combined
Japanese Korean and Mexican Rosso
Mexican does cocktails and ceviches I
did a Korean steak tartare and I was
doing creative sushi knees so it was
kind of fusing some of the flavors at
the same time oh yeah it's like
legendary now but from what I understand
like in the first year you were like two
weeks away from not making payroll yes I
actually had to borrow money from my
friend Jim to make payroll one time
because we were essentially two weeks
away from closing we almost never opened
because there were no liquor license is
available and we had to wait six months
to open before to finally get a liquor
license but the first year it was we
actually had the bank was coming and
starting to ask questions and we had my
wife Nancy was great at making charts so
she showed him a chart that actually is
continuing to grow Nancy that's here
today yeah
yes so and so we were able to convince
the bank to hang on for a little bit and
then we and what really changed for you
two things happened within one month
Frank Bruni who was the food critic for
the New York Times picked us as the best
new restaurant in the country in the
whole country in the whole country and
Food & Wine magazine pickney is one of
the best new chefs
so bingo overnight we've been on a
weight ever since and that was like to
the year that we had opened and we just
like knock on wood you know have been
open for 10 years now how do you thank
someone for that yeah
you can't I mean that's we constantly
Nancy has actually told Frank through
many many times if we have a child will
name them well because it is the dish
Tim we want you to sign and I'll ask you
as you do could have a meal with anyone
past or present who would it be
a couple people one my wife Nancy Jimmy
Hendrix and also the Beatles but I have
met Ringo Starr but I want to meet Paul
so you're totally invited thank you
sounds like a great a great dinner and
it'll be great entertainment as well Tim
Cushman thank you we appreciate thank
you for having me our pleasure and for
more on Tim Cushman and the dish you can
head to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com